Daniel: All right, the next presentation
is by Sanjeev Namjoshi, and this
presentation is going to be called
developing next gen Active Inference
Tools, broadening Accessibility,
Educational Resources, and the Software
Ecosystem.
I'm going to start this talk right now.
Sanjeev: Hello everyone, and thank you
for being here.
My name is Sanjeev Namjoshi.
Daniel: I'm just going to restart it.
Sanjeev: Machine learning engineer
working at the AI.
Daniel: Services firm just because it's a
little quiet.
All right, restarting the talk.
Sanjeev: Hello everyone, and thank you
for being here.
My name is Sanjeev Namjoshi, and I'm a
machine learning engineer working at the
AI services firm Kung Fu AI, where I
primarily focus on computer vision
projects.
Today I'm going to be talking to you
about my progress toward providing
greater accessibility, visibility, and
knowledge of active inference and the
free energy principle.
I'm excited to be presenting this
material at the active inference
symposium this year because the idea of
an enacted ecosystem of shared
intelligence perfectly captures the
philosophy that underlies the projects I'
'm currently engaged with.
I've spent the last seven months on
sabbatical for my job to work exclusively
on an active inference textbook and
related tools, presenting chapter
presentations, code reviews, and
receiving feedback weekly at the active
inference institute.
The institute has provided a space where
interdisciplinary research can flourish
as the connections and influences of
active inference spread to other fields.
It has consistently fostered the spirit
of collaboration and shared intelligence
that I wish to embody in my own work.
As part of this ecosystem, I intend to
continue closely working with the
Institute to provide materials that will
bring active inference to a much wider
readership.
I originally chose this project when I
saw the great potential in the active
inference field and couldn't help but
make a comparison to the state of deep
learning in 2006, when neural networks
were one of just many possible models
rather than the dominant choice in
academia and in industry.
This, of course, all changed in 2006 when
Hinton and his colleagues released the
Deep Belief Network paper, which is
generally understood as the start of deep
learning as we understand it today.
After some hardware innovations and the
release of the Wellknown ImageNet Library,
, we started to see coverage and success
of AI in the news as well as in academic
research.
But in 2012, deep learning truly provided
its value with AlexNet, and for the first
time, deep learning achieved better than
human performance on image detection
tasks.
But this was just the start.
What followed was a proliferation of deep
learning all across industry and research.
.
I've added in some Wellknown milestones
just to highlight the explosion of
progress in deep learning in the last
decade, though there is so much more here
that we could discuss.
So what about the state of active
inference as a field?
From my perspective, active inference
lies in the same position as deep
learning.
In 2006, influential and on the brink of
exploding in popularity, this paper which
is from contributors at the Active
Inference Institute, shows the current
growth of publications in the institute
and its community in active inference.
In the last three years, the active
inference field has seen a number of
important milestones.
Here I show just a few that broaden the
scope and attention to the field.
We had the first International workshop
on Active Inference in 2020.
We had the first active inference
symposium and the founding of the active
inference institute.
Then called the active inference lab.
We had the release of the Par at all 2022
textbook and the Pymdp Python package,
and I see myself now as perfectly poised
to bring active inference to greater
visibility and attention.
This is in part because of the current
academic interest in deep reinforcement
learning and generative modeling working
alongside the institution and other
organizations.
My aim here is to provide some of the
fundamental materials to capture the
attention and notice of machine learning
researchers and students to bridge this
gap to bring active inference into its
renaissance.
To this end, I've been working for the
past seven months on Sabbatical to finish
work on a comprehensive textbook.
The aim of the textbook is to provide the
tools to bring active inference to a
wider audience, primarily those in
machine learning research and applied
fields such as robotics, and to decrease
the challenge in learning the material
largely by separating it from much of the
neuroscience background that is usually a
prerequisite.
This decrease in prerequisites means labs
will have to spend less time helping
students becoming acquainted with the
field, and researchers outside of
neuroscience will find this book an
accessible entry point that uses
terminology familiar to machine learning
rather than neuroscience and fMRI image
analysis.
All derivations are in one place
currently in the field.
Many derivations are spread across
different papers, even behavioral papers
instead of just technical ones, and it's
hard to know where to look if you want to
understand a particular equation or
concept.
Part of the success of deep learning in
the last decade has come directly from
focusing on narrow improvements to
specific aspects of the modeling.
There are many open questions in areas of
research, such as how to prune policy
trees, exploring second order
optimization rules for state and
parameter updates, and scaling active
inference.
The increased accessibility for
researchers would also lead to many new
industry applications, such as autonomous
vehicles, robotics, video game design,
and AI.
The textbook would also put a spotlight
on Bayesian mechanics and invite
contributors and contributions from
researchers as this exciting nascent
field grows and develops.
Part Four is largely a literature review
and can be very helpful to those writing
about active inference from fields such
as philosophy, psychology, sociology, and
many others.
And the historical context sections that
are part of this book provide a lot of
that context, as Active Inference is
built upon decades of research in
neuroscience, psychology, and many other
fields, and also draws upon current work
in many fields that have emerged in the
last 25 to 30 years.
Finally, LaTech reproducibility may offer
interesting ways to rearrange the book
and integrate it with the code for an
online only experience.
Now I'd like to share with you some of
the progress of my textbook and the
general structure.
The textbook is divided into four parts.
The first part introduces fundamental
concepts to set the stage.
In particular, I have focused here on
presenting wellknown statistical ideas
from the perspective of an agent modeling
its environment, who states it must infer
from an observed noisy signal.
The second part focuses on continuous and
discrete state space formulations of
active inference, where the algorithm of
focus for the continuous state space
formulation is active generalized
filtering.
Part three, which I'll begin writing in a
couple of months, focuses on a sketch of
Bayesian mechanics and the required
background designed with the knowledge
this field is still dynamically, changing
and evolving.
Here I will focus on some of the
fundamental concepts and ideas, as well
as code simulations to allow readers to
get a deeper and more intuitive
understanding of some of these
challenging ideas.
Finally, part four is a systematic
literature review that covers all the
various applications and extensions to
active inference that have been innovated
in the last six to eight years.
These applications include things like
robotics, all the behavioral modeling and
neuropsychiatry, and human and animal
behavior, theory of mind, and so on.
The extensions talk about how
applications of active inference can be
used to talk about dynamic systems more
generally, and apply to things like
ecosystems and to economies and other
types of things like governance, and so
on.
As of this week, the rough drafts of part
one and two are complete, and ten
chapters have been presented to the
Active Inference Institute.
In support of this textbook are four
separate tools that I will discuss over
the next few slides.
But before I do that, I would like to
first highlight some special aspects and
features of my approach to this textbook.
.
The major focus is on writing this book
for a machine learning audience or
students learning in this and adjacent
areas.
Neuroscience is out of scope for this
book.
Many of the recommended and even optional
prerequisites that are shown here are
typically known by undergraduate students
in science and engineering and certainly
by graduate students in these fields.
Nonetheless, the book is written to be
readable by those that desire to focus on
everything that is, the math, the code,
the concepts, those that just want to
focus on the math but are not interested
in implementation, and even those that
may skim over the math and just try to
understand the ideas intuitively.
One thing that's very important to me in
trying to express these ideas clearly is
by spending a lot of time working on
typesetting and style, which is very
important to successful learning.
So I would spend a lot of time attempting
to make my work clear and readable.
To this end, I have margins which collect
specific key terms for references later,
which you can see in some of these
figures that are shown here, and these
terms will eventually correspond to the
ontology project ongoing at the Active
inference institute.
Margins also provide further explanation
to accompany the text, and this will be
useful to readers who want more detail
and explanation.
There's a large focus on building an
intuitive understanding of the concepts.
For example, importantly, all algorithms
are explained from scratch.
In this book, we typically start with a
description of the agent environment
modeling problem.
We then start the book with a univariate
case, extended the multivariate case,
then we introduce variational inference.
We add dynamics, generalized coordinates
where applicable, hierarchical models,
action and also learning and other
modifications we might add to our models.
.
We have a very big focus on figures
clearly walking the reader through the
text and giving detailed visualizations
of important concepts and in terms of how
the textbook is set up.
The early part of the book focuses on
basic concepts such as hidden state
estimation, that is, estimating the
conditional distribution of a latent
variable given some observed data.
The aim here is to explain the modeling
paradigm in the context of an agent
attempting to infer the states of the
environment, that is, the interaction
between a generative model and a
generative process, a perspective that
differs from the Bayesian inference style
that is normally taught in universities
and many introductory textbooks.
Typically, introductory textbooks on
Bayesian inference focus on parameter
estimation or learning, and part one
introduces the expectation maximization
algorithm as a way to explain the
connection and separation between hidden
state inference on the one hand and
parameter learning on the other.
Additionally, a large focus has been
placed on variational inference, which is
explained in detail, and the book
features a catalog of all the different
forms of variational free energy and
expected free energy in the literature
and how they can all be derived from one
another.
The book also covers Rau and Ballard
style predictive coding terms and ideas
such as key ideas such as prediction
error minimization as well as clear and
intuitive explanations of fundamental
concepts such as surprisal.
The textbook focuses heavily on building
intuition through derivation and the
general flow of most of the chapters is
to set up the problem that needs to be
solved which is defining an interaction
between the agent and the environment.
Showing the elements needed to solve it,
which is usually random variables and
parameters that form a joint distribution
or generative model replacing probability
distributions with their algebraic
formulations and then moving through the
algebra to a final analytic or gradient
based equation.
The readers should be able to recognize
most equations in the literature.
Upon reading this book, I'm also making
extensive usage of Bayesian networks and
other types and styles of graphical
models such as factor graphs will appear
in part four.
There are hundreds of custom figures that
have been created so far, and the figures
are detailed to give the readers a deep
understanding of the different types of
content that is covered throughout the
books, and also summarizes much of the
information and equations that are
pervasive throughout the active inference
literature.
Another important focus of the textbook
is that many of the models that are
presented are also shown in pseudocode,
which should aid the reader in
implementation.
And finally, each chapter is filled with
numerous what I call experiments.
And these experiments correspond to the
Jupyter notebook and try to show the
application of a concept in a simulated
environment.
So a lot of these experiments start out
by generating data.
So we have some kind of generative
process and then we have that data passed
to a generative model or the agent which
then attempts to either perceive and
learn from that data and even act on it.
And the example that's shown on the right
margin here, this is just a perception
problem on a continuous grid which has
been divided into pieces for the purpose
of the simulation, but represents a
continuous state space.
And the agent in the bottom left corner,
shown as a mouse, has a prior belief
about where some reward food is and its
environment.
But it then needs to perceive from
sensory data that it observes the true
location of that reward or food which is
obscured or occluded in some way by the
mist that's shown in that figure.
So these types of experiments give the
reader a better sense of how to apply
these statistical ideas to a real world
situation so we can understand how it
might apply to some kind of autonomous
agent.
Next, I'd like to cover and shift my
attention toward Jupyter notebooks and
videos and like to note that upon
publication of the textbook these Jupyter
notebooks will be released on GitHub and
should be fully reproducible using Docker
and other version handling tools.
One of the big emphasis on the Jupyter
notebooks is it has to be a direct
correspondence between the equations and
explanations in the code and in the text.
.
This will build a direct understanding
and show applications of the concepts
explained.
Notebooks are filled with simulations and
visualizations many that appear in the
main text.
And in addition to that, I have also over
the last seven months been presenting
chapter presentations to the Active
Inference Institute.
So far, a draft version of the first ten
chapters of the book have been recorded
at the Active Inference Institute and
these are just some sample slides that I'
've prepared that try to explain these
concepts in great detail.
In the final stages of writing this
textbook, video lectures will be re
recorded and released alongside the book.
.
I also plan to create detailed code
walkthrough videos that walk through the
different examples in the Jupyter
notebooks.
Now I'd like to talk about a few planned
future resources I'd like to work on
after the book is complete, or toward the
final stages of the book to have further
support and educational tools.
Some of these planned future resources
include a software suite in Python to
enable an alternative learning approach
for those who do not wish to learn about
the algorithms from scratch, and this
will expand the possible landscape of
engagement as Pymdp already exists.
I will not be working on a discrete
statespace Python package, but I'd like
to fill the space for things like active
generalized filtering, and also just an
availability of different types of
simulations of Bayesian mechanics as it's
currently defined today, or at least the
different versions and varieties of some
of those key concepts.
I'm also very much interested in
interactive learning, and my aim would be
to have these preset simulations concepts
that are explained in text, with various
simulations interspersed in the form of
plots and demos and other visualizations.
.
And the idea would be that the user could
manipulate sliders and knobs to tweak
various parameters that would help aid in
learning as they get a feel for how these
systems behave, especially ones most of
these systems we talk about are dynamics,
so seeing how they change over time.
The Active Inference Institute has made
tremendous progress in the past couple of
years to provide a collaborative
environment for researchers and for
students of active inference.
I hope to be part of this ecosystem as I
continue to support the spirit of
accessibility and collaboration, and I'm
excited to continue to contribute to this
ecosystem of shared intelligence and look
forward to what we can build together.
I would like to thank the Active
Inference Institute for hosting my
presentations, code reviews, and feedback
sessions and inviting me to present at
the symposium, and also thank my employer,
, Kung Fu AI, for letting me take time
off to write for the past seven months.
Please feel free to contact me at any
time.
Email is the easiest way, but I'm also
available on the active inference
institute discord.
If you would like access to the textbook
and related materials, please send an
email requesting access and I can get you
set up.
And that's all I have for today.
Thank you very much.
Daniel: Awesome.
All right.
Thank you, Sanjeev.